on garde et vous voilà devant un athlète
olympique à tester vos habiletés
personne qui a envie d'essayer la frime
il veut venir à l'expérience olympique
et voit aussi mvr l'idée de cette
expérience immersive conçu par
l'entreprise montréalaise gsm concept
est de vous faire comprendre tout
travail qu'il ya derrière une
performance de haut niveau tout en
s'amusant bien sûr voir le temps et si
ça à bout de ligne ça peut à l'humain
petites lumières pour des enfants qui
disent moi je suis intéressé j'allais
nager comme mark tucker j'allais courir
comme bruny surin
ben on a réussi notre but justement pour
s'assurer que l' aventure soit la plus
réaliste possible
les athlètes ont été mises à
contribution bruny surin a été
consultant pour le départ du sprint et
pour moi personnellement le faible bon
on a eu des médailles aux jeux
olympiques championnats du monde mais si
j'ai pas le
la possibilité de partager de
transmettre mais mes connaissances m'a
passionné tout ça pour moi ça vaut
favori pour des émotions garantis il
n'ya là ça lausanne grâce à un immense
écran panoramique on revit presque comme
si on y était les meilleurs moments de
nos athlètes à travers l'histoire et
pour un voyage dans le temps il y à la
portion musée avec photos et images
d'époque entrevues et témoignages de nos
athlètes bref un joli moment une visite
pour mieux connaître notre histoire
olympique s
marie josée turcotte radio canada
montréal